bonjour à tous bienvenue au parlement
européen on est ensemble pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne dans cette
émission je vous emmène à herstal en
belgique petite ville qui a réussi à
faire plier l'industrie agroalimentaire
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant les
grandes surfaces donnent leurs invendus
aux associations d aide aux plus démunis
un exemple à suivre peut-être pour son
voisin français qui tentent de légiférer
sur la question mais d'abord l'actualité
le type est de retour le traité
transatlantique cette semaine se déroule
au 11e round de négociations entre états
unis et union européenne
mais ce traité n'en finit plus
d'inquiéter politiques et société civile
alors cet accord est il mort né avant de
recevoir mes invités et d'en débattre
c'est la question qui est posée par hugo
barbieux
ils étaient près de 250 milles à défiler
en plein centre de berlin mais aussi l
think i ou à bruxelles en marge du
sommet européen
tout d'un coup on part tous convaincants
qui démocratiquement pendant des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années
objectif contrer le type le traité de
libre échange entre les états unis et
l'union européenne
un combat largement relayée par les
politiques ils font pas un marché unique
pour élever les normes environnementales
ou sociales
tout va être alignée par le bas
libéralisation des marchés publics
tribunaux arbitraux convergence
réglementaire la commission européenne
surtout la conclusion d'un tel traité
serait bénéfique pour union en termes de
croissance et d'emploi et elle le fait
savoir
les consommateurs européens et gagneront
sur les prêts et sur le choix
la commissaire au commerce cécilia
maelström le garantis les négociations
prennent en compte les inquiétudes des
citoyens notamment sur la question
sensible des tribunaux arbitraux à
travers le déclare qu'il ya eu et qu'il
ya encore un manque de confiance de la
part du public vis-à-vis de l'équité et
de l'impartialité du mécanisme de
règlement des différends entre
investisseurs et alors que le 11e tour
de négociations vient de s'ouvrir
la commission n'est pas près d'avoir
convaincu la population
une population qui a du mal à être
convaincus comme le souligna hugo
barbieux à l'instant des manifestations
et même les politiques qui s'y mettent
et qui emboîte le pas alors ce traité
est il mort né et c'est sylvie goulard
que je reçois pour répondre à cette
question bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne membre du groupe adl eux et
vous connaissez très bien vous occuper
au sein de ce parlement des questions
économiques et en face de vous c'est
pascal durand bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député européen membre du groupe des
verts français vous êtes ancien
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts et au sein de ce parlement
vous siégez notamment la commission du
marché intérieur et de la protection des
consommateurs sylvie goulard je me
tourne vers vous près de deux cent mille
personnes qui manifestent à berlin on a
vu les manifestations en marge du sommet
européen la semaine dernière
est ce que vous diriez que ce traité est
mort-né vu l'opposition qu'il suscite au
sein de la population
le débat a été assez mal engagée avec la
commission précédent je crois qu'il faut
l'admettre c'est un traité dont il faut
arriver à parler un peu calmement il ya
des avantages et des inconvénients il
faudra voir comment on arrive à les
pondérer et si le résultat le jour où on
aura négocié vaut la peine ou pas
personnellement je suis je suis un peu
effrayé par l'ampleur d'une mobilisation
avec parfois des slogans qui n'ont pas
grand chose à voir avec le contenu alors
qu'est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
d'intéressant payeur de grave
ce qui est intéressant c'est l'ouverture
d'un certain nombre de marchés pour mai
entre nos entreprises par exemple les
produits agricoles européens
si on arrivait à les vendre aux états
unis en protégeant les indications
d'origine comme on est arrivé à le
négocier avec le canada ça pourrait être
positif
al'inverse l'arrivée de produits
alimentaires américains qui
correspondrait pas à nos normes il faut
être vigilant voulait que le repaf aux
hormones introduit mais là une mission a
déjà dit qu'a priori on n'allait pas
dans cette direction là il ya une autre
chose qui est très préoccupante c'est
que la commission négocie pour le compte
des états encore une fois le mandat a
été donné par les musiques commerce
extérieur de nos pays est-ce qu'ils
assument leurs positions ou pas est-ce
qu'ils vont devant les opinions en
disant qu'il ya des avantages et des
inconvénients potentiels
il ya aucun accord l'asie sera favorable
à l'europe à 100% mais la vraie question
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe si on fait
pas d'accord qui fixera les normes
mondiales
est-ce qu'il va vous savez qu'il ya un
accord qui a été conclu entre les états
unis et le pacifique qui a été relâché
vers une ya quelques jours je suis allé
au congrès j'ai discuté avec pas mal
d'interlocuteurs américains les
européens doivent
conscience qu'ils ne sont plus au centre
du monde géographiquement et en terme de
pouvoir salou est en train de devenir
sylvie goulard c'est que clairement les
états unis cet été ip c'est pas leur
priorité il regarde plutôt vers l'asie
vers le pacifique c'est ça que nous dit
ce que je dis c'est que il y a dans le
monde des partenaires que ce soit la
chine que ce soit d'autres pays d'asie
qui contribue pour une part importante
au commerce mondial et que ces pays
peuvent avoir tendance à faire avec les
états unis des accords qui ne sont pas
favorables à nous mêmes donc si on
renonce aux tic l'une des questions je
voudrais poser c'est qu'est ce qu'on
fait est-ce qu'on est encore présent
dans le jeu ou pas ouais pascal durand
si on renonce au type le risque c'est de
se voir imposer les règles qui sont
celles actuellement en cours en asie
notamment en chine
est-ce qu effectivement c'est pas le
risque de passer à côté de nos propres
valeurs et de nos propres notre propre
règle je pense exactement le contraire
exactement je pense qu'on pose de
problème à l'envers c'est à dire que le
fait d'essayer de négocier maintenant
des normes mondiales va nécessairement à
baisser les normes européennes qui sont
en construction et qui sont difficiles à
construire parce que là où sylvie
goulard peuvent raison bien sûr que
c'est bien le commerce est d'essayer
d'arriver à trouver des normes et que
tout le monde fonctionne à peu près sur
les mêmes à condition que ce soit de
bonne norme la difficulté que nous avons
c'est que l'europe actuellement est en
panne
elle est en panne pour arriver à
construire de manière durable des normes
sur la sécurité sur la santé et quand
j'entends sylvie goulard dire bah oui
mais c'est bien si on peut vendre nos
produits agricoles mais depuis quand les
américains vont accepter d'ouvrir leurs
marchés sans que nous mêmes nous
ouvrions le nôtre face à n'existe nulle
part et on sait très bien que s'ils ont
des questions agricoles
ça bloque depuis très longtemps à l'om
c'est d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu on
contourne parce que nous ne souhaitons
pas les consommateurs européens ne
souhaite absolument pas se retrouver
dans les logiques de la culture
intensive avec vous l'avez dit les
hormones des ogm enfin que ces terres et
à tout ce qui est aux états unis le
chlore et toutes les les
les difficultés que nous aurions à
pouvoir vivre avec ça alors le la
question qui se pose c'est pourquoi
faudrait-il faire un accord avec les
etats-unis pour quoi et bien
effectivement parce que quelques grands
groupes notamment les groupes de l'eau
voudrait se voir ouvert les marchés et
le moment on nous explique que c'est
bien pour les pme les tpe et que ça ira
c'est faux jeudi aucune offre un poète
n'y a pas de bataille des affirmations
d'un côté elles sont absolument pas
prouvé
donc ça c'est pas ne s'est pas une
bataille parce qu'une bataille faudrait
qu'ils aient des fondements là on nous
indique que ça serait peut-être 0 5%
croissance ça relève de rien d'abord 05
faut voir ce qu'on perd en face quand
bien même dans le raid 0 5 en termes
d'emploi le mexique qui a fait un bel
accord avec les états unis a vu son taux
de chômage exploser mais bon est le
nôtre est déjà beau donc la réalité
c'est que en l'état les états unis et
l'europe c'est le premier marché mondial
il n'y a pas de problème douanier ou
presque il n'y a pas de problèmes
d'implantation des uns ou des autres
donc la seule je ne sers à rien pour
vous si à faire baisser les normes bien
sûr qu'il a une volonté un grand nombre
de grands groupes c'est comme le secret
d'affaires et comme tous ces sujets là
veulent normes et de manière mondiale de
manière à être tranquille dans
l'exercice de leur commerce
salah le après la question on voit bien
sûr pas tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui
a été
on va avancer dans la conversation alors
justement vous parlais tout à l'heure du
traité avec la zone pacifique
il ya eu parce que moi ce qui m'intrigue
c'est qu'on a négocié un traité avec le
canada qui est prêt clé en main et il
attend d'être entérinée depuis quasi
deux ans ou trois ans par le parlement
européen et il est toujours sur la table
il n'est pas il n'est pas entérinée il
n'est pas votée donc il n'est pas mis en
place donc à partir du moment où déjà le
traité de libre-échange avec le canada
n'est pas mis en place
je me dis est ce qu'il n'est pas aussi
logique de se dire que ce traité
transatlantique en fait n'est pas près
d'être mis en place non plus est-ce
qu'on s'affole pas pour aller les choses
qui arrivent et il faut quand même être
précis pour les auditeurs le traité le
canada est un traité qui est signé oui
et les procédures de ratification des
traités internationaux même si la france
signent un traité tout seul il ya une
procédure derrière ça prend un certain
temps pour le type on est au stade de la
négociation ont négocié des jeunes gens
d'accord avec ce qui a été dit sur
l'accès au marché je pense que c'est
important l'accès au marché américain
pour un certain nombre de groupes par
exemple la raison pour laquelle je l ai
discuté à washington c'est que étant
sur les questions financières je
m'insurge qu'on n'est pas introduit les
services financiers dans le champ de
l'accord là je pense que les européens
ont fait une erreur et que les intérêts
des groupes financiers européens ne sont
pas bien défendu mais je crois qu'il
faut arrêter aussi d'opposer les grands
groupes et les pme
on sait très bien on sait très bien
qu'un certain nombre de petites
entreprises vivent aussi de commandes
sont étranges de collaboration avec des
grands groupes la france est un pays
dans lequel il est assez grand groupe
donc l'idée que alstom puis se vend plus
facilement des les rails ou des trains
aux etats unis c'est pas forcément
négligeable ni pour un groupe comme ça
ni pour les pme qui travaillent à sa
suite
il ya trop de simplification dans cette
affaire je n'ai pas dit que c'était la
panacée je ne partage pas certaine
désillusion qu'ont fait miroiter et
j'essaye ou serveuse est abstenue sur ce
vote
à l'époque oui parce que j'estime que à
ce stade les choses sont confuses comme
je voulais dit les ministres devraient
être derrière on a un système
communautaire qu'il faut expliquer aux
gens la commission ne négocie pas comme
ça en sortant un lapin de son chapeau
il ya des nids ce qui donne un mandat
way et qui se dérobe lorsqu'il s'agit
d'aller faire l'explication vis-à-vis de
leurs opinions
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont exclu les
services financiers pourquoi est-ce-que
ils sont ce quelle est leur position sur
les tribunaux arbitraux etc
alors les points importants je
rapidement très rapidement pour dire que
la négociation est là c'est un
euphémisme ce que dit sylvie goulard et
je sais qu'elles le pensent en plus un
peu comme moi il ya un déficit
démocratique majeur dans le
fonctionnement le parlement a donné un
mandat à la commission la commission
négocie elle tord le parlement dans la
précédente mandature et les verts
d'ailleurs ont voté contre
donc certains sont abstenus mais le
problème qu'on a c'est que la commission
négocié de manière totalement opaque
ouais on n'a pas accès aux documents
open enfin je dis rien c'est pas ce qui
se passe on sait pas ce qui se passe ces
négociations se font de manière on est
on a des documents dans une data room
c'est dans une salle de lecture on peut
pas prendre en photo enfin bref passons
mais un déficit démocratique majeur et
c'est toujours très dangereux
pourquoi est-ce qu'on cache et chose
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne sait pas ce qui
se négocie et pourquoi on ne sait pas
sur quel mandat les choses ce n'est
qu'alors justement là-dessus à ce propos
c'est matthias fekl secrétaire d'état au
commerce français qui a exactement la
même position vous oui j'en écoute
il est inacceptable que des enjeux
fondamentaux soit négocié en secret et
en opacité la france ne l'acceptent pas
ne l'acceptera pas et ne l'acceptera
jamais gelé indiqué encore récemment au
haut représentant du président obama
nous souhaitons des évolutions sur ce
sujet si rien ne change dans un avenir
raisonnable c'est-à-dire dans les jours
qui viennent
au 11e tour de négociations et dans le
courant de l'année 2016 la france en
tirera les conséquences demandera
l'arrêt des négociations et nous
travaillerons avec nos partenaires
européens en ce sens alors sylvie
goulard je me tourne vers vous est ce
que vous diriez que matthias fekl est
hypocrite puisque il s'agit donc d'un
mandat de négociation qui a été aussi
négocier avec les états on peut en effet
pas sonné sur un sujet pas de remarque
la première pour vos auditeurs la
négociation d'accords internationaux est
une prérogative de l'exécutif ok quand
le quai d'orsay négocier avec l'iran
j'ai pas vu monsieur fabius venir
expliquer cartes sur table ce qui se
passe il ya toujours eu une opacité
qu'on peut combattre mais j'aimerais
qu'on la combattent
autant au niveau national qu'au niveau
européen on laisse entendre que c'est
l'europe qui fait les choses de manière
vague j'ai commencé ma carrière dans la
diplomatie
j'ai toujours été impressionné par la
capacité de se créer des diplomates
après il ya une autre aspect qui selui
tactique
quel est notre intérêt vis-à-vis des
américains jusqu'où peut-on aller dans
la transparence que je souhaite mais qui
doit être aussi une transparence habile
si vous abattez votre carte dans une
négociation même pour quelqu'un qui
achète un appartement on sait très bien
qu'à un moment dans la négociation de la
part de bluff quoi il ya toujours une
part de bluff
donc il ya un enjeu démocratique il ya
un enjeu tactique il faut aussi et
d'abord de la compréhension pour les 200
pêche pas de chercher d'en faire plus ce
monsieur fait qu'elle je crois peut
faire une meilleure explication comme la
commissaire peut faire une meilleure
explication alors pascal durand et
écouter ce que ce qu'a fait monsieur
fekl c'est tout simplement qu'il a
entendu les populations et il a compris
ma part d'opportunisme politique mais il
ya aussi une part d'intelligence
politique s'est noyé hier qu'il a
compris que les populations c'est comme
les ogm c'est comme sur d'autres sujets
à un moment les gens disent non on n'en
veut pas les tribunaux arbitraux le fait
qu'on puisse pas
contrôler de manière alors bien sûr
qu'il ya des parties des négociations
qui doivent être secrète qui donne mais
bien sûr mais là c'est l'ensemble
milliers secret donc ça n'est pas
possible le mandat de négociation a été
enlevée le mandat il est minime et le
mandat il a été donné on nous a donné le
mandat avec des mois et des mois de
retard une fois que de toute façon il
était quasiment publiques lassées on est
toujours en décalage mais le problème je
répète ya un déficit démocratique majeur
mais par ailleurs la question la vraie
question c'est pourquoi faut-il
actuellement négocié les normes
ouais encore une fois avec les états
unis alors que nous ne sommes pas au
clair nous mêmes sur nos provinces de la
première puissance commerciale mais lang
a des raisons liées au fait de conclure
mais les ago déjà avec les états unis ça
marche très bien
donc c'est un hommage chaleureux dernier
c'est 50 pendant quasi misait le même
temps qu'elles produisent des
appellations travail et de saint-grat
pour les agresseurs les les entreprises
qui n'ont pas accès aux marais est très
grave pas d'accord avec les alliances de
lutter contre l'agriculture intensive
les vous êtes aussi défense de mars que
les américains ont des nombreux débats
pas les à l'économie vous me demandez
les autres droit social sur les chinois
en moi ces thèmes il ne sera bon pas
fait ce qui me frappe si l'adversaire du
type note battue moi je n'en ai actifs à
bakassi jamais été fendre là je veux
défendre les valeurs européennes et bien
si on est d'accord
eh bien écoutez comme à liège sur
l'oréal pascal durand sylvie goulard
merci on vous mettra pas d'accord mais
moi je vous donne rendez-vous essayons
pas de négociations on est d'accord
merci à vous nous on continue direction
installe en belgique dans la banlieue de
liège
comme vous le savez en france on est en
train d'essayer de légiférer sur le
gaspillage alimentaire notamment dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire et frédéric
daerden le maire de cette municipalité à
imposer une législation pour limiter ce
gaspillage dans les supermarchés alors
peut-on prendre exemple sur nos voisins
belges c'est un reportage de jérôme
rabier
comme chaque matin alphonse broughton
fait le tour des rayons du supermarché
où il travaille alors que d'autres sont
chargés de les remplir lui retire des
produits de la vente avec des règles
bien précises
donc on regarde les dates qui ne sont
plus vendable nous retirons de la vente
nous de ce canon comme ça nous avons une
trace de ce que nous donnons aux
associations comme nous avons terminé le
rayon nous allons mettre ça au frais
pour respecter la chaîne de froid et
vers 9 heures 9 heures caisse
l'association bière et puis vient le
chercher dans un véhicule réfrigéré net
ce qui doit y être on se retrouve dans
un frigo à l'arrière une pratique
ancienne dans ce supermarché mais
désormais obligatoire dans la commune
depuis 2012 la mairie a en effet imposé
le don des invendus alimentaire aux
associations le maire se rappelle
toutefois de débuts difficiles il y à de
la résistance au changement aux
changements d'habitudes et notamment au
niveau de la grande distribution au fait
qu'on leur ait pose la redistribution de
ses invendus
on s'est dit localement nous pouvons
également agir et c'est comme ça qu'on
essaie de trouver une formule pour
pousser la grande distribution à
redistribuer leurs avant qu un recours
déposé par des enseignes mauvaise
volonté flagrante
il aura fallu une première amende de
5000 euros infligée à un magasin pour
que tous s'engagent pour les enseignes
de la ville comme pour les associations
habilitées à collecter la mécanique est
désormais rodée et de nouveaux outils
pourraient voir le jour pour optimiser
cette pratique
carrefour en belgique ne demanderait pas
vu ce que chaque magasin le fasse que
chaque association puisse en profiter et
qu'on passe par un logiciel au niveau
national où chaque association soit
contrôlé par la sq a bien évidemment par
le gouvernement et que les invendus que
nous mettons à disposition des
associations soient également cherché et
donc redistribuer à ceux qui en ont
besoin
montagneux l'exemple d'herstal a depuis
essaimé des dizaines de communes du pays
ont repris cette idée et la région
bruxelloise comme celle de wallonie ont
engagé un processus législatif ou
généraliser cette obligation
une aide précieuse pour les associations
caritatives chargé de redistribuer comme
ici à herstal où près de 200 familles
dépendent de cette association
il ya des zones à la meilleure de son
programme un peu ce qu'il ya là comme
les brocolis sont bons mais on peut les
distribuer de mer nous avons 4 5 5
magasins donc on fait une tournée et
nous donne les invendus l'aurait pas eu
assé rien qu'avec le carrefour et que le
nombre de personnes qui augmente plus la
conjoncture c'est une bonne chose que la
loi soit quand même sorti parce que bon
on a de la plus belle marchandise et
plus en quantité pour donner aux
personnes afin d'accompagner cette
obligation
les autorités sanitaires ont modifié les
règles de contrôle pour la grande
distribution comme pour les associations
allégeant notamment la traçabilité les
barrières ont été revus pour les banques
alimentaires surtout au niveau de la
traçabilité pour que cette lourdeur
administrative qui est clairement à
considérer comme une barrière pour les
entreprises
à juste titre pour des associations
caritatives on ne peut pas passer les
trois quarts de sa journée à remplir des
papiers et bien l'afsca l'agencé en a
tenu compte et a permis par cet arrêté
ministériel et cet assouplissement
spécifique pour les banques alimentaires
a permis la de faire perdurer l'activité
de l'association caritative
l'exemple d'herstal donne désormais des
idées à d'autres
le parlement européen a voté en juillet
dernier un amendement demandant la
commission européenne d'agir sur ce
sujet une urgence quand on sait que 20
millions d'européens dépendent de l'aide
alimentaire pour survivre
alors comment lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire comment obliger
nos industries agroalimentaires a donné
leurs invendus c'est la question que
j'ai posée à marc tarabella
bonjour bonjour je suis ravie marc
tarabella de vous recevoir aujourd'hui
alors vous êtes bourgmestre danthine une
ville qui n'est pas très loin d'ici et
mère pour nos voisins français
est ce que quand vous voyez ce reportage
vous vous dites que on a encore du
chemin à faire
on peut saluer l'initiative de frédéric
daerden le maire un d'herstal convoi
dans le reportage
mais on est encore loin du contenant le
gaspillage alimentaire en europe pour
donner un chiffre c'est 90 millions de
tonnes par an c'est-à-dire 179 kg par an
par habitant
et ça c'est pas le consommateur qui est
responsable de tous en fin de chaîne il
est responsable d'une vingtaine de kilos
mais c'est tout tout au long de la
chaîne alimentaire à partir de la
production de ce qu'on ne récolte pas de
ce que l'on gaspille sur les différents
trajets entre la récolte la
transformation puis on l'emballage les
emballages abîmé et donc il faut
évidemment faire un effort et l'exemple
effectivement de la commune d'herstal de
la ville d'herstal et de frédéric
daerden est emblématique de montrer que
l'on peut faire mieux
maintenant on a contraint la
distribution allait donner on a aussi
assoupli la loi parce que dans certains
pays comme la belgique auparavant les
commerçants qui donne l aliment étaient
taxés par la tva alors que quand ils
détruisaient ils n'étaient pas taxées
alors que pour pas pour exemple la
france est en ce moment en train de
discuter sur une législation globale
pour obliger l'industrie agroalimentaire
a donné ses invendus en france vous
pouvez déduire de vos impôts ces dons à
hauteur de 66 % c'est des dons en nature
mais c'est au même titre qu'un autre
deux associations ce n'est pas le cas en
belgique non en belgique on vient
d'abaisser la tva donc assez aller quasi
2 0 comme c'était le cas en france
auparavant maintenant on peut peut-être
aller plus loin effectivement pour
encourager encore plus à donner ce qui
est un vendu qui peuplaient tendu mais
qui est toujours propre à la
consommation
c'est évidemment quelque chose qui vient
en aide aux banques alimentaires aux
associations caritatives pourquoi parce
que les aides européennes ont diminué
on s'est battu il ya trois ans pour les
maintenir un niveau qui était similaire
à celui qui était auparavant il y avait
une menace de d'une baisse de budget de
80 %
c'était inacceptable parce que 20
millions de citoyens européens à dépend
de l'aide alimentaire et c'est une
population qui va en croissant
il fallait évidemment alors on voit
il ya quelques jours qu'un supermarché
moyen peut gaspiller jusqu'à 225 milles
équivalent repas par an ça représente
quand même énormément en termes de doses
et qu'il faudrait selon des observateurs
une approche plutôt volontariste et pas
coercitive est-ce que passer par un
texte de loi comme ça va être le cas
certainement en belgique comme ça va
être le cas en france c'est pas une
mauvaise manière de faire non parce que
l'expérience de herstal et qui a essaimé
ailleurs et là pour le montrer dès lors
qu'il y as coercition les dons sont en
augmentation et de meilleure qualité
comme ça été dit dans le reportage donc
ce qu'il y avait une nécessité
maintenant c'est toujours mieux d'avoir
un dialogue il fallait adapter les lois
aussi fallait écouter la distribution
qui disait écoutez c'est pas normal que
nous soyons taxés quand on donne plutôt
que de détruire la législation au niveau
fiscal a été aménagé notamment en
belgique
je crois qu'il faut il faut évidemment
vers le dialogue mais à un moment donné
il faut pouvoir aussi prendre des
mesures plus coercitives pour inciter
vraiment ou obliger à donner car c'est
un scandale de jeter de la nourriture
est toujours propre à la consommation
quand on voit les besoins de la
population précarisée alors justement
vous parlez de besoin d'après la
population précarisée vous vous évoqué
le chiffre de 20 millions de pauvres qui
sont pris en charge par ce type d' aide
alimentaire en europe sur 550 millions
d'habitants ça paraît absolument énorme
mais quand on voit les besoins est ce
que c'est pas un emplâtre sur une jambe
de bois que de se dire on va aider à
l'aide alimentaire mais il ya quand même
d'autres leviers à mettre en place quand
même certainement il faut il faut
probablement aussi éduquer un peu là la
population des citoyens quand on voit
sur un emballage à consommer de
préférence avant telle date
ça veut pas dire que si on arrive à la
date limite c'est plutôt lui quand il ya
ce qui dépasse une semaine deux semaines
dans le frigo là il faut le moins il
faut le manger si le pot n'est pas bon
ben c'est excellent donc il faut faire
la différence à consommer de préférence
avec à consommer jusqu'au il est clair
que du du filet américain rappelle
avions préparé ça c'est plutôt compliqué
donc pas connaître la date il faut jeter
si on n'a pas si on n'a pas consommé
très clair donc il ya aussi je dirais
d'éducation à mettre en place et
l'éducation à l'école
aussi par rapport aux citoyens savez il
ya la nourriture que l'on que l'on jette
malheureusement parce qu'elle peut être
réutilisé les pommes de terre que l'on
ne mange pas c'est quand même selon la
seconde le lendemain on parle de 1,3
milliard de tonnes de denrées
comestibles qui seraient jetés aux
milliards de m3 ouais 1,3 milliard de
tonnes au niveau mondial un bon mondial
oui oui ça ça me semble excessif que ces
90 millions de tonnes au niveau européen
les états unis des gets 40% la
nourriture produite est jetée aux états
unis c'est évidemment un scandale et
donc il faut réduire à tous les niveaux
parce que par rapport à l'emballage
aussi les emballages abîmé ça qu'on doit
jeter la nourriture est peut-être
toujours propres à la consommation
donc elle peut être dès ce stade la
dévier vers les banques alimentaires et
les associations caritatives
alors là on voit que la france s'apprête
à légiférer la belgique a préparé
quelque chose l'union européenne donc le
parlement européen ici dans ses murs il
ya une résolution qui a été votée en
juillet dernier sur cette question
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour mettre en
place une directive globale au niveau
européen plutôt que de faire ça pays par
pays
c'est évidemment un souhait que nous
avons je crois qu'il faut invité la
commission à légiférer et intelligente
ils veulent légiférer de manière
intelligente pour la soie légère pas
beaucoup il ya un an qui sont en place
donc il faudrait que la commission
malheureusement elle seule allée pour la
priorité quoi elle a le pouvoir
d'initiative nous ne pouvons rien faire
nous en tant qu'initiative parlementaire
au niveau européen si la commission ne
propose rien auquel doit proposer
effectivement je pense que l'idéal
serait d'avoir une règle commune à tout
le moins à toute l'europe pays d'europe
donc on s'adresse à des groupes comme
carrefour qui sont implantés dans toute
l'europe donc ça paraît très logique non
oui ça paraît logique par rapport à la
distribution mais jeudi il faut pas
nécessairement se focaliser uniquement
sur distribution ce serait bien par
rapport à essayer décès mais par rapport
à ce qui se passe en france - en
belgique partout en europe mais aussi à
tous les stades de la production à
l'arrêt de la récolte essayer faire en
sorte que l'emballage aussi soient
étudiées telle manière qu'on a qu'on ne
jette pas il ya les films qu'ils le font
qu'y emballages
l'emballage du jambon sépare deux trois
quatre ou six tranches tout dépend de la
composition de la famille ici avec les
six tranches serait dommage oui c'est la
personne seule évidemment n'aurait
d'autre choix que de gaspiller est donc
clairement il ya soit tous les salariés
inventée là dessus oui je pense
merci beaucoup marc tarabella nous avoir
un petit peu éclairé sur cette île à
vous merci
nous on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
vous retrouvez à meknès vers la semaine
prochaine merci à hugo barbieux à cécile
6 ou de l'avoir aidé à préparer cette
émission ciao à tous bye bye
on